it was such a high value man then you
wouldn't even have to have those
problems to fix exactly everyone else
well everyone has problems everyone's
having problems that's how they picture
of course but then you saying that you
can't come home and like if you came
back to your girl and saying oh baby
there's nothing this happened is that
you're automatically a like I know
I have problems yeah but I was saying
that based on what you said because you
said that you kept having to fix these
problems that's what you said no that's
so so I'm saying based on that why would
a guy bring you his problems if you you
said yourself you don't like that you
keep being a fixer no I'm not saying
that I don't like being a fixer I'm just
saying that's who I am actually I'm like
that's the energy I vibrate is I'm just
a fixer like but that's not even like in
relationships that's like we're gonna
appreciate my life